[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
voilà un peu plus d'un an que nos vies
sont chamboulés par la pandémie de kobe
de 19 avec l'arrivée de nouveaux
variants une campagne de vaccination
pointé du doigt pour sa lenteur et bien
la perspective d'une sortie de crise
semble encore s'éloigner une démocratie
dont le fonctionnement est lui aussi
impacté alors comment agir aujourd'hui
pour l'avenir
que faut-il réinventer bien on va en
parler aujourd'hui avec emmanuel hirsch
professeur d'éthique médicale à
l'université paris saclay emmanuel
hirsch bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation sur rt france alors je
vous êtes également un président du
conseil pour l'éthique de la recherche
et l'intégrité scientifique est votre
dernier essai tout juste publié la
démocratie confiné et chroniques éthique
d'une année de pandémie aux éditions
erès alors à l'heure où nous
enregistrons cette grande interview et
bien on se pose encore la question d'un
éventuel troisième confinement c'est le
suspense les français sont dans
l'attenté ce que vous avez le sentiment
finalement et bien qu on repart à zéro
par rapport à l'année dernière
d'abord merci d'invitation l'évier de
ker en fait j'ai pourtant de pouvoir
participer à cette émission
effectivement on est dans un moment
démocratique important d'abord après un
an de gestion de la crise chacun
apprécie ce qu'ils ont été de
concertation nationale notamment pour
éclairer les choix qui sont des choix
délicats dans un contexte difficile
d'incertitude effectivement de nouvelles
échéances sont devant nous uniquement le
confinement mais la complexification
quelque sorte le des données
épidémiologiques et également vous avez
vu tout le débat sur la dangerosité des
variants donc on est une société qui est
totalement percuté
c'est uniquement la société française
c'est au plan mondial n'a d'ailleurs des
populations dans le monde qui en
souffrent davantage les personnes les
plus vulnérables sont les plus exposés à
une situation comme celle qu'on vit
aujourd'hui donc on a des choix à faire
des choix redoutable à privilégier le
moindre mal
on a vu par exemple en france qu'on a
privilégié les personnes les plus
vulnérables ou tout début de la pandémie
ça fait l'objet de controverses ont d
ores que les jeunes ont peut être aussi
prioriser
les choix de démocratie des choix
politiques qui justifie encore une fois
de la concertation la critique de moi je
pose c'est qu'on a effectivement une
démocratie confiné c'est à dire la vie
démocratique au niveau de la
représentation parlementaire au niveau
du processus décisionnel et 13 en
question pour moi d'un point de vue de
mes valeurs
ce qui n'a pas empêché la démocratie
française c'est à dire les gens sur le
terrain mais dans d'autres pays aussi de
se mobiliser d'être à l'initiative de ta
d'une inventivité
ils ont permis de faire face aux plus
difficiles notamment dans le père et du
premier confinement donc notre
démocratie se porte bien et le mérite
peut-être mieux de la part de ses
dirigeants
ce qu'effectivement l'état d'urgence
sanitaire il a été prorogé le 20 janvier
dernier jusqu'au 1er juin 2021
ce que vous dites aujourd'hui finalement
c'est qu'il est temps de sortir de cette
logique où le sanitaire dit que toutes
les décisions
je n'ai pas une position aussi tranchée
lorsqu'on a affaire à une pandémie on a
affaire la morbidité et la mortalité
donc des enjeux de santé publique mais
il faut arriver à trouver le bon
équilibre entre santé publique et vit la
société et on voit l'impact tout à fait
déterminant on est encore une fois sur
l'ensemble des démocraties à regarder ce
qui s'est passé aussi aux états unis on
voit l'impact direct sur la vie
politique du pays
des choix qu'on est amené à faire qui
sont des choix contraint c'est à dire le
politique est confronté à l'incertitude
ils comptent difficilement la situation
donc on est au mieux dans le padd
inactifs et ce qui est important c'est
de mobiliser autour d'un projet auquel
les gens puissent adhérer
ça demande de la loyauté sa demande de
la transparence sa demande de la
concertation et s'il ya crise
aujourd'hui notamment dans nos
démocraties mais pas que c'est une crise
en quelque sorte de déchéance parce que
la population attend davantage bien sûr
dans la vie démocratique dans un
contexte démocratique notamment d'être
participatif d'être j'allais dire partie
prenante de la décision que dans des
pays qui ont des régimes un peu
différent et qui d'ailleurs gèrent à
leur manière la pandémie avec des
résultats quelque fois
satisfaisant ça nous avons par exemple
la question
pardonnez moi je vous coupe les français
n'ont pas été assez écoutés depuis un an
pendant cette pandémie
les français engagés ont pris des
initiatives dans les lieux les plus
inattendus de la république
regardez on a parlé des soutiers des
invisibles de la république qui ont pris
des initiatives extraordinaire donc j'ai
eu toute une mobilisation mais il ya
toute une intelligence une intelligence
du réel que dirige en vigueur j'arrive à
le comprendre parce qu'ils sont saturés
uniquement pas uniquement d'ailleurs par
la pandémie il ya tout un ensemble
d'enjeux politiques géopolitiques
j'arrive à comprendre la complexité mais
on a un esprit d'enfermement là où
devrait y avoir de l'ouverture et je
pense que il n'y a pas d'incompatibilité
entre prendre des décisions importantes
et difficiles et ont discuté
c'est pour ça que nous on appelle avec
un groupe qu'on a constitué à des états
généraux par exemple de la pandémie
notamment parce qu'on s'installe dans le
long cours
il y à la phase difficile aujourd'hui
mais elle va être récurrente dans ses
conséquences
donc il faut qu'on s'installe dans une
société qui est confrontée à des risques
en tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué
sanitaire isation c'est à dire comment
d'une certaine manière le médecin les
scientifiques peuvent être prescripteur
on pourra pas rester
j'allais dire avec ses dominante faut
maintenant qu'on vive avec une réalité
est une réalité qui nous exposent à des
risques et conviennent ensemble des
risques on est prêt à accepter à la fois
d'un point de vue individuel et d'un
point de vue collectif
j'ai derrière moi voulions fond d'écran
vous le voyez l'opéra de paris bien
quand vous discutez avec les
professionnels qui sont des artistes
puisque sur les professionnels ils vous
disent qu'on pourrait peut-être revoir
des décisions qui sont systématisées
alors que ans les contextualiser en
prenant compte intelligence des
professionnels on pourrait peut-être à
ouvrir avec des conditions très précises
le respect des règles sanitaires
un théâtre ou à l'opéra oui c'est la
même chose quand vous hiérarchiser les
choix prenez la question des étudiants
on a 2 millions 700 mille étudiants
france beaucoup d'entre eux
confinés chez eux et la situation est
plus douloureuse pour les plus
vulnérables rapport à d'autres qui ont
encore une vie relationnel qui ont des
moyens économiques
donc il ya la question de la justice qui
est aussi à prendre en compte dans une
démocratie quand on fait des choix les
plus vulnérables regard des légendes atd
quart monde qui sont où les gens qui
sont dans la rue on a deux cent mille
personnes qui sont dans la rue en france
je vais pas vous faire l'inventaire de
toutes les personnes qui sont les plus
exposés aux conséquences des décisions
qu'on prend doivent être prises en
compte prioritairement alors je dirais
que prada menée par rapport à la
question vous me posez trouve que l'état
français le président république après
des engagements forts en disant on
laissera personne sur le bord du chemin
nous sommes un pays qui peut s'honorer
de l'accompagnement économique pour
permettre aux gens de supporter pour eux
ce qui souvent insupportable la
fermeture de magasins
mais derrière tout ça vous avez des
échouements dramatique vous avez des
commerçants qui se suicide
vous êtes des gens qui avaient des
projets d'existence sont totalement à
braser par la réalité da ponte vie c'est
pas la faute du gouvernement c'est pas
l'incompréhension du gouvernement par
rapport à la réalité
mais si on doit prendre des choix
difficiles et on aura de plus en plus
des choix difficiles à engager
il faut que ce soit concertée pour que
les gens l'acceptent l'année ce qui se
passe en ce moment aux pays bas mais
comment vous vous comprenez aujourd'hui
que finalement et bien les décisions
politiques elle était juste finalement
trop savoir si on doit confiné recond
fine et depuis un an c'est ce qu'on vit
finalement gestes barrières confinement
déconfinement on n'est pas tellement
sortie de ce schéma là comment vous le
comprenez qu'il ait pas eu finalement
d'autres stratégies de penser une mise
en place disons qu'on peut répondre à
votre question un an plus tard c'était
difficile il ya un an de voir ce qu'on
serait confronté peu de personnes ont
anticipé le pire
alors vous allez dire qu'on aurait pu
vraiment anticiper un apport début
j'avais sorti en 2009 un livre sur la
pandémie grippale les préparations on
avait développé par rapport au h1n1
donc j'avais des modalités de
préparation ne revenons pas sur
l'histoire on a une réalité qui est ce
qu'elle est il faut me semble-t-il
comprendre que la décision c'est un
dilemme c'est à dire qu'est-ce qu'on
biologie qu'est-ce qu'on priorise et pas
uniquement dans l'accès aux traitements
ou dans l'axé en réanimation
donc pour moi ce qui est important c'est
l'ouverture on a des schémas qui sont
systématisées et j'allais dire qu'il
parte de la tête supérieur de l'état
alors qu'il faudrait d'une certaine
manière qu'à tous les niveaux de la
société les gens s'approprient les
enjeux et soit reconnu dans une
excellence d'une compétence pour
intervenir et participer de ce qui est
d'une certaine manière la recomposition
d'une société par rapport à ces défis
donc ce que j'appelle l'intelligence du
collective est totalement notre
collectif est totalement négligé je vous
donne un exemple concret pour pas d'être
dans les généralités
vous avez depuis le 15 mars 2002 en
france la loi droits des malades qualité
du système de santé qui est restaurer la
démocratie au sanitaire la démocratie en
santé tout ça dans la dynamique des
années au sida des années 80 où il y
avait aussi une confrontation
une épidémie laquelle on a apporté des
réponses démocratique dans les années 80
90 et ou du débat on associer les
personnes malades les professionnels à
tous les arbitrages là depuis le début
de la pandémie la démocratie en santé
qui a pourtant des instances
représentatives comme la conférence
nationale de santé a été totalement
bafoués et a fait par exemple certain
nombre de personnes qui auraient pu
aspirer à être traités parce qu'ils
avaient des besoins de traitements
vitaux
pendant la période de confinement n'ont
pas été vous vouliez vous avez a
mobilisé toutes ses intelligences et on
ne peut pas dire un an après le début de
la pandémie
on n'a pas appris de la pandémie vous
avez un conseil scientifique qui
remarque que le nom présidé par jean
françois delfraissy
mais qui est plutôt une approche
médicaux j'allais dire scientifique de
la réalité d'après débit toute la
dimension socio politique aurait pu
relever d'un autre conseil scientifique
en sciences humaines et sociales vous
êtes des sociologues des anthropologues
vous avez des psychologues vous avez
tout un ensemble de compétences qui ne
sont pas considérées comme recevables
dans la manière d'éclairer la décision
et je trouve que c'est
mettre entre parenthèses ce qu'était une
compréhension une connaissance une
capacité de proposition et qui manquent
aujourd'hui douloureusement alors qu'on
est peut-être à quelques heures d'un
confinement dont on nous annonce qu'il
sera dur donc vous voyez à quel point
nous devons avoir une analyse très fine
de la réalité de la manière quand on dit
on rentre dans un nouveau possible
confinement il ya des personnes qui sont
confinés depuis quasiment un an
donc comment on met de l'ouverture et on
ne peut pas considérer une démocratie
vit véritablement l'amplitude de ses
possibles et l'amplitude de ses valeurs
quand elle est à ce point confiné pour
aujourd'hui existait dans le débat
public
il faut aller dans les médias et oui à
quel point heureusement que les médias
sont les vraies ressources de notre
démocratie aujourd'hui c'est à ce qui se
passe au parlement n'est pas vraiment
représentatif de ce que dépense et les
françaises et les français éprouvent
ressentez ont envie de faire pour lutter
vous parlez des personnes confinées
depuis presque un an maintenant on pense
bien évidemment aux personnes âgées
notamment il ya tout un débat
aujourd'hui de savoir si les plus de 75
ans est bien doivent rester confinées
doivent se sacrifier finalement pour le
reste de la société qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
le mot sacrifice n'est pas un mot à mon
avis adéquat ce qui est très dangereux
dans le discours politique
c'est un discours souvent très punitive
très culpabilisant et on al'impression
effectivement que c'est le sacrifice
comme les héros dans les guerres qui se
sacrifient qui donnent leur vie pour
sauver la nation mais je pense pas que
ce soit avec cette vision on prend les
choses en compte les personnes sont
responsables on a une société d'adultes
et lorsque d'une manière extrêmement
péjorative le présent république a dit
un jour que nous étions des porte
couleurs des procureurs on n'est pas des
procureurs on n'est pas en train
d'insulter l'état on est des acteurs
témoins qui auraient davantage partie
prenante
j'allais dire du processus décisionnel
puisque c'est à nous une fine et
d'assumer les conséquences des choix qui
sont faits donc je pense qu'il faut
responsabiliser les acteurs
emmanuel hirsch ont fait une pause et on
en parle tout de suite en revient dans
un instant
[Musique]
bonjour si vous nous rejoignez dans la
grande interview emmanuel hirsch
professeur d'éthique médicale est avec
nous pour partager son regard sur cette
crise sanitaire et les conséquences sur
la démocratie et la société on en
parlait à l'instant à julien compliquées
entre le chef de l'état et les citoyens
notamment parfois avec des des phrases
qui peuvent heurter les français donc ce
sont des procureurs par exemple la
société est ce qu elle a encore en
capacité d'accepter aujourd'hui ce que
l'état impose vous parliez des craintes
que vous aviez comme ce qu'on peut voir
aux pays bas en ce moment par exemple
d'abord genre match bien sûr ceux qui
nous gouvernent
c'est pas simple de gouverner dans un
contexte aussi incertain encore une fois
on n'a pas qu'une confrontation à une
pandémie on a aussi une réalité
géopolitique avec aussi des menaces au
niveau de l'environnement il ya beaucoup
d'éléments à prendre boutabout et on
peut se demander s'il n'y avait pas un
autre mode de gouvernance notamment est
ce que c'est vraiment au président la
république au premier ministre d'être
sur le front en toutes circonstances
est-ce qu'ils ont la légitimité pour
face et tout un ensemble de la question
que l'on peut poser aujourd'hui il ya eu
des mots maladroits essentiel et ce qui
est essentiel ou pas n'a pas uniquement
le mot procureur et voyez à quel point
notre société est confrontée à une
réflexion sur ses valeurs
on sait que dans une crise de cette
nature mais dans toute crise importante
il y a des points sur lesquels il faut
renoncer on peut transiger sur un
certain nombre de principes
on voit par exemple en matière d'éthique
médicale sur la question de la
priorisation sur la question du
consentement à tout un ensemble
d'éléments qu'on pourrait développer
dans une autre émission mais il ya des
fondamentaux et ce qui est important
c'est que la personne qui incarne en
quelque sorte ses fondamentaux et qu'il
garante en quelque sorte de ce qu'est
notre république de ce qu'est notre
démocratie qui soit juste la fois dans
ses attitudes mais également dans le
processus décisionnel vous voyez ce
qu'on demande c'est pas de la
transparence illusoire avec des effets
de manche c'est que toutes les décisions
qui seront prises soit acceptable
c'est à dire qu'elles soient justifiable
on parle par exemple de proportionnalité
dans une décision on parle de loyauté
décision donc le processus décisionnel
doit être transparent c'est à dire on
doit nous expliquer et pas uniquement
12,1 des leçons de morale comme le
premier ministre instituteur la première
et de la troisième république le fait
dans ses conférences de presse on est
des adultes
on est des personnes responsables on a
une capacité de discernement
est ce parce que mon prix d'ailleurs
quand on est dans un ehpad vous avez
identifié des décisions déloyale depuis
le début de cette pandémie
je pense qu'il ya un processus
décisionnel qui est confiné qui est
secret je vois pas en quoi nous devons
attendre comme ça
verdict comme encore une fois des
accusés dépendant de la décision du
politique puisque c'est le présent
république qui assume l'entièreté des
décisions mais d'avoir un conseil de
défense sanitaire dont on ne sait pas ce
qui s'y dit et de quelle manière on
aboutit à des arbitrages pour moi
quelque chose d'inquiétant même si
ensuite comme c'est le cas au moment où
on se parle il ya des discussions avec
les représentants des différentes
définir partis politiques ou différentes
entités représentatives de la société
française mais ce qui pour moi est
inacceptable un moment où on communique
un moment où on partage des savoirs
c'est qu'il n'y ait pas de concertation
et qu'on n'ait pas le sentiment
véritablement que les décisions sont
prises d'une manière transparente d'une
manière argumentée
cette défiance si je peux juste vous
répondre à votre question mais oui c'est
la première pandémie convient en direct
avec autant de médias ou des grands
médias comme le vôtre mais aussi les
réseaux sociaux et donc l'information
circule même la désinformation circulent
çà aurait demandé une communication
hauteur des enjeux qu'on est il de la
communication gouvernementale
si c'était garder les distances lavez
vous les mains est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
pu développer une communication précise
pour les gens qui se retrouvent confinés
au domicile avec les éléments pratiques
bref il ya toute une intelligence
pratique
qui fait qu' on a l'impression que il y
à des résolutions au niveau
gouvernemental selon des critères qu'il
faudrait mieux définir et qui nous sont
imposés de telle sorte qu il est
effectivement un sentiment de défiance
puisque d'abord il ya des contradictions
dans les décisions on va pas reprendre
l'inventaire de tout ce qui a été
affirmé d'une manière péremptoire et
qu'on a été obligé à reconsidérer du
jour au lendemain on ne va pas faire
l'inventaire de toutes les
préconisations qui ont été lancées dès
le départ en matière de santé publique
rappelez-vous dans les ehpad recevoir
par se voir fermer par enfermé avec des
conséquences pour des personnes qui sont
non pas morte
duco vide mais mode de solitude
rappelez-vous aussi de tout ce qui a été
dit autour du port du masque ou pas j'ai
pas faire l'inventaire
il va jusqu'à la stratégie de
vaccination qui une fois lancée a été
totalement reconsidérer parce qu'elles
ne relevaient pas d'une véritable
analyse de ce qui était la réalité
sociale et d urgence donc je baissais en
parenthèse pour dire on a besoin de
concertation et c'est pas tout de nous
dire qu'on a des experts via le conseil
scientifique donc est présidé par le
professeur jean françois delfraissy est
pour moi quelque chose de très
intéressant
on a un travail qui est fait par des
experts qui produisent des rapports et
puis on accessibilité c'est aaron accès
à ces rapports on peut se faire une
opinion
ensuite ce qui m'intrigue c'est le
processus d arbitrage
je donne juste un exemple très
intéressant et qui est pour moi tout à
fait bouleversant du conseil
scientifique a dit d'une manière
argumentée
il fallait confiné il était urgent ton
fils est rapidement en expliquant aussi
comment on devait confiné en prenant en
compte les conséquences du confinement
vous avez toute sorte de rapport qui
analyse les rapports d'une seconde et
scientifique
ils ont été les conséquences du dernier
confirme en tous les cas du premier
confinement importants et les éléments
de vigilance les points de vigilance à
prendre en compte
aujourd'hui on est dans l'attenté d'une
décision du président république dont
certains disent que s'ils ne dissipe pas
maintenant c'est pour pas donner le
sentiment que le conseil scientifique se
substituer aux politiques et les
décisions politiques doit être j'allais
dire
fyk effectivement mais si ça relève de
quoi ça relève de la confiance il ya un
lien un certain lien de confiance qui
s'est rompue entre l'eau politiques et
les experts et même les citoyens en
verre en règle générale ça relève à mon
avis d'une appréciation que je ne
partage pas de ce qu'est l'urgence quand
il ya urgence quand il ya des impératifs
le politique doit avoir un moment donné
une certaine forme d'humilité pour s'en
remettre d'une manière collégiale après
vraiment discussion à ce que peut être
la préconisation du scientifique
alors je comprends aussi qu'on n'a pas
assez maîtrisé
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure la
société mais quand il ya une situation
d'urgence continue et une situation de
péril a calé j'allais dire la
justification du chef de l'état de
surseoir à une décision donc il sait
très bien qu'il faut la prendre et plus
on attend plus les conséquences sont
difficiles et aussi des hits c'est
d'abord parce que effectivement il veut
montrer que c'est lui qui décide et que
c'est pas jean françois delfraissy
et ce bras de fer a quelque chose de
dérisoire et de puéril dans le contexte
d'une crise sanitaire mais également si
les hits et je ne comprends d'une
manière plus rationnelle c'est parce
qu'il craint les conséquences de la
décision sur la vie publique c'est à
dire l'acceptabilité et est-ce qu'on a
depuis des mois tout mis en oeuvre pour
que la relation de confiance entre
l'état les décideurs et de la société
soit à un niveau tel qu'on accepte ce
que pour certains que certains
considèrent par exemple le prochain
confinement comme inacceptables comme
incompatible avec ce qu'ils sont avec
leurs valeurs mais aussi avec leur
survie voilà donc vous avez d'un côté le
chef de l'état qui dit c'est moi qui
suis le patron et c'est pas jean
françois delfraissy de me dire ce que
j'ai à faire donc on sur soi les
décisions le chef de l'état qui clivent
est aussi j'avais à le comprendre au
niveau d'un dilemme est ce que leur
acceptabilité ils vont être les
conséquences pour la vie la nation pour
l'économie mais également pour chacun
d'entre nous est ce qu'on va pas rentrer
vers un tomb désordre c'est des points à
prendre en compte donc c'est sa
légitimité est véritablement en cause
et encore c'est quand question et
j'arrive à le comprendre mais juste ce
n'est pas par rapport à la réponse qui
pour vous vous paraîtra peut-être un peu
embarrassé ce qui est un peu paradoxale
c'est qu'il ya une défiance profonde
mais il ya aussi une certaine forme de
soumission
c'est à dire les sondages indiquent
malgré tout le chef de l'état plutôt la
part de l'opinion qui sont faits une
bonne opinion
le sentiment que finalement on adhère à
sa politique et à ses choix parce que
malheureusement beaucoup d'entre nous
pense qu'on n'a pas d'autre choix et qu'
il faut il mieux être cohérent par
rapport à une certaine forme de
volontarisme que d'être dans un espèce
de forme d'éclatement de la cohésion
mais quel autre choix on devrait avoir
tel autre choix on pourra voir
aujourd'hui avec ces nouveaux variants
qui arrive avec encore ces nouvelles
incertitudes
d autres choix et sont multiples pour
autant que les exports là on est parti
sur un a priori c'est le stop and go
c'est à dire face à l'aggravation de la
situation
le seul repli la seule stratégie de
repli
c'est le confinement mais est-ce que
c'est envisageable sur un très long
terme
déjà on voit que c'est difficilement
envisageable un an après et donc je
pense qu'il va falloir qu'on vive avec
la réalité de risques qu'on prenne des
décisions collectives en disant comment
on s'organise comment on apprécie ce qui
est prioritaire par rapport à ce qui
l'est moins
un exemple pour moi la vie sociale la
vie culturelle surtout en situation de
crise c'est prioritaire voilà pour
donner un exemple précis mais peut-être
que j'ai peur de le dire donc ça mérite
du débat de la concertation pour qu'on
puisse à dos et des décisions difficiles
qu'on devra de toutes les manières
reprendre la société ne survivra pas à
une succession de confinement une
société c'est pas de confinement
c'est la liberté c'est la créativité
c'est le sentiment d'exister
d'appartenir
c'est être créatif d'une certaine
manière mais c'est aussi être en bonne
santé morale pour assumer c'est sa
citoyenneté et pour respirer
d'une certaine manière à réaliser un
projet pour moi l'enjeu fondamental
c'est de reprendre donc à d'états
généraux en de l'état dans le cadre
d'une certaine d'une concertation de
reprendre l'expertisé qu'on a développé
depuis un an et pour dire quel type de
projet démocratique pour les mois et les
années qui viennent puisque vous
très très bien colonne est inscrit dans
un long terme et avec également une
responsabilité internationale vis-à-vis
des plus vulnérables
puisqu'il dit à plus vulnérables qu'on
le pense dans notre société mais plus
vulnérables aussi dans d'autres sociétés
donc cette approche me semble-t-il doigt
est à la fois nationales européennes et
internationales il ya besoin d'une
manière qu'on réfléchisse sur
l'environnement d'une manière planétaire
il ya besoin à mon avis de se mettre en
accord dans une réflexion publique
politique au niveau international donc
on a des instances qui pourrait être
aussi mobilisé il n'y a pas plus l'om s
il ya le duo il ya d'autres instances
qui pourrait être partie prenante d'une
réflexion urgente sur comment on va
réorganiser le monde puisqu'on sait que
ces défis selon quels critères quelle
valeur et le principe de justice
d'équité beaux yachts et voilà tous ces
débats de quelle que soit des
compétences de cet abri de sa tribu le
président république
ce ne sont pas des débats qu'on en
solitaire avec soi et avec j'allais dire
le huis clos de quelques personnes qui
sont les gouvernements quelques
confidences
alain doivent maintenant les meulières
cette confrontation
on arrive au terme de cette interview
peut-être à un hameau un pur pour
conclure aujourd'hui beaucoup sont
angoissés finalement par les nouvelles
perspectives est ce que vous avez
néanmoins un motif d'espoir nous
partager aujourd'hui j'ai plus comme
motif d'espoir
d'abord ce qu'on a réalisé des faux la
france la mobilisation des citoyens
toute la créativité tout l'adaptation
toute cette agilité pour moi c'est un
capital extraordinaire il se trouve
qu'il ya une vraie vitalité de ce côté
là de la vie démocratique et donc on
peut se reposer en confiance à mon avis
sur cette expertise pour autant qu'elle
soit reconnue et qu'on en tire un
certain nombre de conséquences au niveau
de l'organisation de la société
dans le contexte peut-être du
confinement mais surtout demain puisque
on sera dans l'encours le mot important
et on avait beaucoup développée dans le
contexte du sida c'est vivre avec la
pandémie et vivrait que la pandémie
c'est vivre tout d'abord et donc il ya
réinventer la vie à réinventer nos
priorités et à être reconnu dans notre
capacité d'assumer les uns les autres au
plus près des réalités du terrain nos
responsabilités ma critique la plus
fondamentale la plus farouche
c'est à l'égard d'un gouvernement d'une
part qui nous déresponsabilise d'autre
part nous culpabiliser et d'autre part
enfin qui dit assumer vos
responsabilités
je pense qu'il ya une incompréhension
entre ceux qui nous dirigent et ceux qui
vivent aujourd'hui la réalité ceci a
donc je dis il faut créer des liaisions
des médiations et je veux que le
parlement par exemple dans ce domaine
devraient davantage investi ainsi qu'un
sa forme de notre entité de
représentation merci à vous et emmanuel
hirsch en avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france je le rappelle donc vous
êtes professeur d'éthique médicale à
l'université paris saclay vous publiez
la démocratie confiné chronique éthique
et d'une année de pandémie aux éditions
erès cette émission est à revoir sur
notre récit ter transports tv à écouter
également en podcast merci pour votre
fidélité
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]